the jogan experience I like seeing Neil
Magny win that that that's a guy who's
been around forever who's Ying biggest
movie star in the planet what was that
was that one of your phones oh Joey Diaz
showed us the crackhead chucking
competition oh my God this D crackhead
20 feet and he goes I want to thank God
for blessing me with the talent he's so
big that BL with the talent to thr CRA
dude is [__] y there it is how did
you how did you find that so quick pull
this up
Jamie crackhead throwing competition
crackhead
throwing damn 12' 9 in that's not
bad goad this is the same
C oh [__] that was a 13 oh my god let's
go to
the you know what that's like 18 ft bro
he that 20
ft bro this is crazy
23t now listen to what he says listen to
what he says listen to what he says when
they talk to
him hey this is Leo our first winner of
the first annual crackhead chalky
competition you got anything to say Leo
hey man I just want to say thank God for
blessing me with the talent D's missing
five teeth okay okay God bless all right
all right if I was Dana White I would
have F that dude I was said what are you
doing right now bro listen I'm going to
give you I'm going to give you I'm going
to give you some money we're going to
move you down to Miami I'm going to give
you some money for just six months of
solid training it might work it might
not work let's find out I have a feeling
you got a talent I got a feel I got a
feeling you got a tal for [__]
[__] like car peran and [__]
Jesus crackheads
translates that's a lot of weight to MMA
yeah 100% that guy looked like a house I
think that's you teach that guy how to
punch people that's a DK
looke